er gilt als einer der grössten köpfe der
physik der nobelpreisträger wolfgang
ernst pauli formulierte 925 das nach ihm
benannte pauli prinzip eine quanten
theoretische erklärung dafür wie ein
atom aufgebaut ist doch nicht nur das
pauli sagte auch das neutrino in der
theorie voraus und das 25 jahre bevor es
tatsächlich beobachtet werden konnte und
noch etwas sollte unvergessen bleiben
der äußerst mysteriöse pauli effekt der
physiker war bekannt dafür dass in
seiner anwesenheit experimente
misslangen geräte kaputt ging und
maschinen zu bruch gingen teilweise
bekam er deswegen sogar labor verbot wie
kann das sein klicks um science-fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen und danke für euren
super spannenden themen vorschlag aus
der community
wolfgang pauli war nicht nur einer der
bedeutendsten physiker des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts sondern ganz sicher auch
ein schräger vogel schon mit 13 jahren
beschäftigte er sich mit physikalischen
aufsetzen und bereits drei jahre nach
seinem abitur hatte er sein
physikstudium mit dem doktortitel in der
tasche selbst der große albert einstein
bewunderte paulis abhandlung über die
relativitätstheorie
doch der hatte neben der physik vor
allem eine sache im kopf party party und
nochmal partie früh am morgen fand man
ihn meistens in der kneipe der deutsche
physiker max born berichtete später
einmal
ich erinnere mich dass er mehr als
einmal die vorlesung um 11 uhr verpasste
in hamburg wurde pauli dann zum
professor er selbst beschrieb das so als
ich nach hamburg kam wechselte ich
direkt vom mineralwasser zum champagner
alles aber kein problem für seine
karriere schließlich sollte er im jahr
1945 nicht umsonst den physik nobelpreis
bekommen zwar 24 befasste pauli sich
intensiv mit molekül spektren und
erklärte diese mit einem inneren
drehimpuls des atomkerns heute auch als
kernspin bekannt ein jahr später
postulierte pauli dann eine vierte
konnten zahl die wir heute als
elektronen spin kennen damit erklärte er
die aufspaltung von spektrallinien im
magnetfeld der physiker entwickelte ein
ausschlussprinzip das heute als pauli
prinzip bezeichnet wird vereinfacht
gesagt
ein elektro nicht den zustand annehmen
denen ein anderes elektronen bereits an
nimmt zwei teilchen gleicher quanten
zahlen können sich also nicht am selben
ort aufhalten
dieses prinzip erklärt auch warum eine
magische anzahl von kern teilchen
elemente besonders stabil macht bzw
dass materie nicht einfach so in sich
zusammenfällt
man soll preislich kam dann paulis
vorhersage eines winzigen neutralen
elementarteilchen hinzu dass die
energiebilanz beim beta zerfall wieder
ausgleichen würde
in einem brief schrieb er dazu an seinen
kolleginnen und kollegen heute habe ich
etwas schreckliches getan etwas was kein
theoretischer physiker jemand tun sollte
ich habe etwas vorgeschlagen was tun
experimentell verifiziert werden kann
die meisten seiner kollegen taten seine
gedanken damals noch als humbug ab hinzu
kam dass paul nicht besonders viel wert
auf veröffentlichung legte neue gedanken
und ideen schrieb er lieber in briefen
dazu paul ii ich kann es mir leistung
nicht zitiert zu werden
bezüglich seiner entdeckung ergänzte der
physiker dann auch dass man sich die
suche nach der quanten zahl als auch
nach dem von ihm postulierten
elementarteilchen sparen könne
beide waren seiner ansicht nach nämlich
keinesfalls messbar damit lage aber
falsch wenn nicht nur die eigenart von
elektronen lieber heute als bin
bezeichnen konnte nachgewiesen werden
auch die spektakuläre entdeckung des
neutrinos folgte ganze 25 jahre später
in der fachwelt war pauli aber nicht nur
wegen seiner wissenschaftlichen leistung
bekannt er genoss einen ganz besonderen
ruf denn er galt als forscher mit zwei
linken händen so heißt es dass er
beispielsweise rund 100 fahrer stunden
brauchte um den führerschein machen zu
können berüchtigt war der physiker auch
bei seiner anwesenheit in den laboren
dieser welt zu einem kuriosen effekt
führte
sobald pauli in der nähe eines
experimentes war funktionierte dieses
nicht mehr aber nicht nur das auch
geräte und maschinen gegen kaputt der
experimentalphysiker otto stern verbot
seinen kollegen deswegen einen fuß ins
labor zu setzen manche physikerinnen und
physiker nannten dieses phänomen das man
auch als pauli effekt bezeichnet im
scherz auch das zweite bayerische aus
schließungs prinzip es ist unmöglich
dass sich wolfgang pauli und ein
funktionierendes gerät im
im raum befinden pauli selbst glaubte
fest daran und nahmen es mit humor bei
einer sitzung der deutschen
physikalischen gesellschaft viel der dia
projekte aus und pauli stand auf um sich
selbst und den pauli effektvoller stolz
zu präsentieren
1950 befand sich pauli an der princeton
university hier brannte der
teilchenbeschleuniger auch der vorfall
in götting ist unvergessen hier gegen
ein wertvoller apparat kaputt und das
forschungsteam vor ort betonte dass es
diesmal ja nicht an pauli liegen könne
schließlich sei dieser jahr zur
fraglichen zeit nicht in der nähe
gewesen doch dem war nicht so paulis
angaben zufolge hatte er wohl genau zu
diesem zeitpunkt bei seiner reise nach
kopenhagen einen kurzen stopp in
göttingen gehabt und ein beispiel belegt
den effekt wie ich finde am
eindrucksvollsten der italienische
physiker giuseppe giannini wollte pauli
einen streich spielen er konstruierte
einen pauli effekt eine helle lampe
wurde so befestigt dass sie
herunterfallen würde wenn pauli eine tür
öffnete alles war präpariert und als
pauli eintrat funktioniert das natürlich
nicht die lampe viel nicht von der decke
ja also es ist praktisch wieder schief
gegangen es ist und bleibt also absolut
mysteriös auch wenn es viele beispiele
gibt und der pauli effekt auch oft
dokumentiert wurde kann er
wissenschaftlich gesehen also kann
bisher wissenschaftlich gesehen nicht
erklärt werden sogar stephen hawking
schrieb später darüber
böse zungen behaupten er brauchte sich
nur in einer stadt aufzuhalten schon
gingen alle dort durchgeführten
experimente schief aber wer weiß
vielleicht findet die wissenschaft
irgendwann mal die erklärung für solche
phänomene denn es gibt sie ja
tatsächlich kennt ihr jemanden mit einem
solchen phänomenen wo etwas immer schief
geht oder immer klappt schreibt in die
kommentare
nichtsdestotrotz wolfgang pauli gilt als
einer der grössten köpfe der
wissenschaft die vorhersage des
neutrinos und die formulierung des pauli
prinzips gelten als meilensteine in der
physik superschwerer elemente die jagd
nach neuer materie anklicken anschauen
und den megacoolen kanal von dr watson
unbedingt abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran